you never know what's gonna happen here  girl it has been all sorts of craziness  it's the vmas right absolutely anyone in  particular are you looking forward to  seeing this evening just a little bit of  everyone you know it's always fun to  come out especially in new york city you  know my home so i'm looking forward to  seeing everyone so good have you heard  the news this evening that miss britney  spears is engaged oh no wow  congrats  congrats girl and we have got to see  your fashion honey because that braid  yeah how long is that parade she's very  long she's taller than me  she sure is a shantae but you are always  bringing it is it going  i didn't know that was he's crazy  i didn't even know that was him i didn't  even know that was you  wait a second is that nick  oh my god  how are you doing queen i'm in the  presence of god  what are you doing nick putin pants that  boy  [Music]